las plantaciones de banano son el
símbolo del escándalo sanitario de la
flor decona y de la vida de Juliette
peloponese está pensionada ha vivido
toda su vida cerca de esta plantación
donde también trabajo durante 45 años
contó cargo y cortó racimos de bananos
esta malla Azul se pone para proteger la
fruta años Durante los cuales manipuló
glordecona y hoy sigue sufriendo las
consecuencias eran granos pequeños
granitos blancos y los agarrábamos así
sin guantes con la mano no sabíamos que
era peligroso
tuve problemas con la tiroides con el
colon debido a la flor de cono
la cifra de personas potencialmente
afectadas por el pesticida asciende a
miles y no solo son trabajadores del
sector Bananero este es policía está en
remisión de un cáncer de próstata cuya
relación con el pesticida es reconocida
pero solo en el caso de los ex
agricultores para el jubilado esto es
una injusticia había una gran plantación
de bananos
durante mis indagaciones tenía que ir
allá
antes no conocía las consecuencias para
nada si martinicas del país más afectado
por este flagelo es porque la clordecona
contaminó toda la cadena alimenticia
la flor decona no se quedó solo en las
plantaciones de bananos después llegó a
las aguas subterráneas Así que también
contaminó el agua y dejó remanentes en
el suelo una contaminación invisible que
puede permanecer en el medio ambiente
durante décadas o incluso hasta siete
ciclos como seguir cultivando sin
envenenar esta fue la pregunta que se
hizo abdultiller cuando se enteró de que
sus tierras estaban afectadas llegué a
este terreno en enero de 2005 y sólo
había bananos
era una gran explotación bananera
y banano Es sinónimo de clordecona este
ex profesor de economía apasionado por
la botánica arrasó con todo y plantó
árboles frutales los únicos que se
salvan del veneno aquí seguramente hay
clor decona en la Tierra y sabemos que
la clordecona se extiende de 5 a 10
centímetros alrededor de la base del
tronco pero no sabemos por qué no sube
al resto de la planta En todo caso
sabemos que estas frutas no tienen color
de cona podemos comerlas sin miedo para
estar seguro y tú analizar su suelo y
sus frutas varias veces
en el caso de la llamada ciruela del
Pacífico no se detectó clor decona ni en
la hoja ni en la fruta y sin embargo en
el suelo teníamos de 0,6 a 1,4
miligramos de clor decona por kilo de
suelo seco igual con la papaya no se
encontró clor decona y el suelo tenía
entre 1,7 y 6 miligramos de clodecona
por kilo de suelo seco el veneno sigue
ahí seguimos sufriendo las consecuencias
y nos dicen que hay un tiempo de
prescripción no el 92% de los
martinicanos están contaminados por el
pesticida todos tienen un familiar O
conocido afectado desde hace años las
asociaciones luchan para que el gobierno
francés te conozca el envenenamiento de
la población local
este colectivo
yo martiniques reune a médicos
Defensores del medio ambiente y
feministas
reparar también es plantear la cuestión
de la investigación para saber cómo
tratar un síntoma por ejemplo
decir a una mujer en edad fértil Este es
su índice de contaminación Esto es lo
que puede hacer para salvar a su hijo a
pesar de la movilización los jueces de
instrucción desestimaron el caso Aunque
reconocen un escándalo sanitario evocan
la dificultad de probar penalmente los
hechos denunciados las asociaciones ya
han anunciado que apelarán la decisión
también consideran la posibilidad de
llevar el caso ante el tribunal europeo
de Derechos Humanos